[Music]
hello and welcome to the take with
sophie ridge live at nine right here in
the heart of westminster
there is one thing that everyone is
talking about in parliament today
who is the mp accused of watching
pornography inside the chamber well the
chief whip is investigating and number
10 say it's wholly unacceptable
and with local elections just around the
corner prime minister's questions was as
heated as ever and if that wasn't enough
the high court has today ruled the
government acted unlawfully over care
homes during the coveted pandemic so
there is lots to get stuck into today as
we bring you takes from all sides over
the next 60 minutes
56 members of this house are under
investigation for sexual misconduct and
that includes three of his cabinet
ministers
lots of claims of sexism inappropriate
behavior and misogyny we are going to be
discussing that this guy is doomed to be
a permanent spectator mr speaker
he's an ostrich
perfectly happy keeping his head in the
sand
and we'll bring you the best bits from
another feisty prime minister's
questions
plus who better to ask about it all than
the most important people that is you at
home we're going to see what our viewers
make of it all here they are say hello
everyone hello bit of a wave
we're going to be hearing from our
viewers panel later on in the programme
and we'll also have some top guests
including the home office minister
rachel mclean labour's shadow chief
secretary to the treasury pat mcfadden
and we'll be speaking to daisy cooper
from the lib dems much more besides
that's all on the take
[Applause]
[Music]
hello this is the take where we discuss
the biggest stories have a look at
promises questions and of course get
reaction from
politicians analysis from my sky news
colleagues and most importantly the
thoughts of our very own viewers panel
well after the sexism storm that was
sparked by coverage of angela rayner
daring to cross and uncross her legs
while sitting down we now know the
conservative chief whip is investigating
reports of an mp watching porn inside
the chamber yeah you really did hear
that right when mines did turn to the
real business of the day boris johnson
and kirstama pulled no punches when
clashing over the cost of living in pmqs
and there were also questions over the
high court ruling that the government
acted unlawfully over care home
residents during covert so let's crack
on here are some of the best bits of the
week so far
this is the the ruling from the high
court government policies and
discharging patients from hospital to
care homes at the outset of the pandemic
were unlawful i expressed my sympathy to
write about member for action on the
line for the subject of this type of
comment in being demeaning offensive to
women in parliament you know if we ever
find who is responsible for it we'll
i don't know what we'll do with them but
we'll be the terrors of the earth 56
members of this house are under
investigation for sexual misconduct and
that includes three of his cabinet
ministers i hope he's also sent a clear
message that there's no place for sexism
and misogyny
all looking down on people because of
where they come from in his party and i
i repeat what i said to her there could
be absolutely no place uh for such uh
behavior or such expression in this
house our growth is set to be slower
than every g20 country except one
russia that the uk came out of coded uh
faster than anybody else that's why we
had the fastest growth in the g7 last
year that would not have happened mr
speaker if we listened
to captain hindsight this must be the
oxford union debating skills we've been
hearing so much about he's an ostrich
perfectly happy keeping his head in the
sand does he think that his 15th tax
rise
has made things better or worse for
working people
what we're doing is making things better
for working people uh than his plans
would do by a mile i can tell the right
orange i listened to him over many weeks
so many years uh this guy is doomed to
be a permanent spectator mr speaker
everywhere you look at labour
administration it is a bankrupt shambles
a vote for labor next week is a vote for
a very different set of persons that's
the difference between labor and
conservative across the country mr
speaker vote conservative on the 5th of
may
[Applause]
you can really tell those local
elections are approaching can't you well
they were the best bits of the week so
far in westminster but what does the
country make of it all we can try and
find out because now we are joined by
our regular panel of viewers great to
see you all thank you very much for
being on the program with us this
evening uh we've got people from across
the united kingdom and also across the
political spectrum to try and take the
temperature of how politicians are
landing their points and guys i wanted
to start off by talking to you about the
high court ruling on care homes a really
important story this uh this of course
is at the beginning of the pandemic when
people were being discharged from
hospital without a cover test
and then of course uh moved to care
homes which seeded uh the um the the
strain the covered 19 in many care homes
so let's try and find out what our
viewers panel make of that are the
government to blame i think we can go
first to uh in michael john let's bring
you in first uh shall we now you are a
labor supporter important to say uh not
the biggest fan of boris johnson
what do you make of the story on
care homes do you blame the government
for um seeding it within care homes
i think i blame the government for using
fine words that don't really have very
much meaning
protective ring
what sort of ring was it
it sounds great
but there wasn't any protection
so the language didn't mean anything
yeah they did as you say they promised
to put that protective ring around care
homes and of course with tragic
consequences
many lost their lives and let's bring
chloe in now shall we just to see
if chloe agrees with some of those
points that ian was just making and
chloe forrest you're a conservative
supporter and you were a nurse during
the pandemic weren't you so i'm
interested to find your own view on this
and what's your experience of whether
people were being discharged from
hospital into care homes and do you
think the government is to blame for
making those mistakes
i think that accountability needs to be
taken across the board so
from care homes to hospitals to any cat
and providers
alongside public health england and also
the government i think the government
have made the pro they made the issue by
promising things before they had the
means to do that such as offering those
tests before
and they had the means to do it
however is it not the responsibility of
care home staff
for accepting patients knowing very well
that they haven't had a clogged test
um is it the responsibility of public
health england to fully inform the
government of what's going on you know
this was at the beginning of the
pandemic where nobody knew anything that
was going on we didn't know how the
virus worked how it
mutated and every time they worked
something out it changed
so we didn't fully know what was going
on
and i think that accountability should
be taken across the board i don't think
it should be one person i want one group
of people that is
you know responsible for that and i
think looking
into that i've seen patients that have
come from care homes that
have not you know been tested for
covered and brought covered into
hospitals you know affecting hundreds
and hundreds of people that must have
been so difficult for you seeing um
those people with covered 19 you know
into hospitals into care homes what was
it like
in just a few words briefly working as a
nurse at that time
it was absolutely it was heartbreaking
you know and we did i sat there and and
held the hands of those people that
couldn't have any anyone with them at
the time and it was heartbreaking but at
the same time you've got to keep other
people safe as well
you know keeping those families out
sometimes has also prevented it being
spread around the families you know into
playgrounds to the grandparents
and i do this you know the ring of
protection
it didn't happen didn't it did it but it
also didn't happen in many other areas
for the example hospitals that you know
they didn't get any we had to accept
every patient through that door
covered no coverage for a lot from care
homes that they never told us they had
covered when they did
uh thank you for sharing your uh
experiences of that let's bring in at
lucy shall we lucia tala who you're in
basin swansea you're a labour supporter
what's your take on how care home
residents were treated
um
well if i want to talk specifically
about moving them out of hospitals
and back into care homes then i
and if i want to lay blame i lay blame
directly on the government because they
made the decision they made the
directive and they're in charge and
whoever's in charge and makes the
decision is the person who's
or are the people to blame so i don't
think you can blame it on circumstance
or we didn't know
they they did it they made that decision
they didn't make another decision they
made that one and that was the one that
caused the virus to run through the care
homes in the way that it did
and and and so they have to take
responsibility for their actions we all
do as grown-ups
and they need to more than anybody else
in this case it's not an excuse to say
well we didn't know what the virus would
do
yeah and
asymptomatic um
uh cases wasn't something that we knew
about that's what boris said today in in
question time and well i thought to
myself well
there are so many
illnesses that are asymptomatically
spread okay thank you so much thank you
so much uh lucy for your thoughts on
that it's frustrating to hear what
everyone has had to say lots of divided
opinion let's bring in rob now shall we
this is rob tyler a conservative
supporter your wife
i think i'm right in saying is it worked
in care homes what do you think the
government is to blame
i don't think the government's to blame
um
to be honest i think kerholms were
expected to be able to work with
infection control
and i think that the
the cohorts themselves were inconsistent
in the occur and in their work
and the staff many were unvaccinated so
we saw a lot of
people being infected possibly by the
staff that were looking after them um so
i don't think we can look specifically
at the government i think there was a
case-by-case situation there's even
situations where some patients are
inclined to wander and it's very
difficult to control where those people
are going in the night sometimes
okay thank you so much for uh your
thoughts are really fascinating uh to
hear and also lots of people with real
experience uh about what happened in
care homes as well if i didn't get you
this time we're gonna talk to you later
in the programme so uh don't worry uh
fascinating to hear what you all had to
say
well uh next it is time now to talk to
our first guest we'll talk to the panel
later on in the programme i can now
introduce rachel mclean thank you very
much for coming in to talk to us this
evening she is the government's
safeguarding minister
firstly on care homes
i think one of our panelists probably
put it best uh that was um when we spoke
to ian michael john he said that the
government promised to put a protective
ring around care homes you didn't should
you be apologizing to people
so obviously it's it's awful to hear
those stories and of course we are
really sorry to hear of of the losses of
people and i've heard those stories from
my own constituents and actually my own
mother's been in a care home so i've got
some lived experience of this and it was
very difficult for everybody so look
there's been the judgment today and i
think the government's been very clear
that are you sorry that's what people of
course i'm sorry on honor of course i'm
sorry for those desperate losses that
occurred and how how could i i not be
i'm sorry for any loss of life i think
it's right that the government is doing
an inquiry we'll look at we'll look at
all of it but i think as some of your um
i just heard the last
section of your your panelists and i
think it's it's clear obviously that we
did we did do what we believe was right
at the time we were following that
clinical advice and it's an entire it
was an entirely
new pandemic that nobody had i just want
to kind of experience with i think lots
of people would give you a lot of
sympathy for the beginning the pandemic
when we didn't know about asymptomatic
transmission
but i'm just going to read you the
government guidance for care homes in
september 2020. remember the judges in
the trial were saying that there was
growing awareness of asymptomatic
transmission as early as march 2020 so
this is september
a small number of people may be
discharged from hospital within the
14-day period from the onset of covert
19 symptoms needing ongoing social care
they will have been covered 19 tested
and have confirmed covert positive
status so as late as september when we
knew about asymptomatic transmission
people were still being discharged from
hospitals into care homes so i just i
just i'm not sure i really buy this
argument that i was at the beginning of
the pandemic we didn't know it was going
on for many many months i think the
point is that we were following the
advice of the the clinicians and the
medical advisors all the way through and
clearly decisions were made in a very
fast-moving situation now we need to
look at what went wrong there of course
we do and that's why we're having the
inquiry but i think the judgement um and
forgive me i haven't had time to study
in detail because it has only just come
out today but i think it did recognize
actually that we did do many other
things right and the vast majority of
our response actually was you know it
was they found in favor of what the
government was doing in terms of
prioritizing testing and ppe for care
home residents so i think if you look
across the whole response obviously we
were trying to keep people safe across
the whole country and it was a very fast
moving and evolving pandemic as we went
through it
um the cabinet of course another big
story uh at the minute in politics is
the cost of living
brought up the prime minister's
questions lots of our viewers be very
worried about it now the cabinet was
asked to come up with ideas to ease the
cost of living crisis this week but you
couldn't spend any money could you it's
a bit laughable well i think we've spent
billions and and people know that we've
put
lots and lots of different support
measures in place to help people with
the cost of living whether it's council
tax rebates or whether it's help with
their energy bills and again i know for
my own constituency that there's a
number of specialist and specific funds
that are available to different
households depending on their
circumstances so it is right that we
help protect people but i think we need
to remember this is a global situation
it's been caused by the war in ukraine a
number of other facts hasn't just been
caused by the i mean course of living
was going up inflation was going up
before the war in ukraine wasn't yeah
there's a number of global factors
obviously the pandemic the global
situation energy prices a lot of these
are outside the government's control and
of course it's right that we protect
people but at the same time we have to
remember that we can't possibly
protect people from every single adverse
circumstance that's going to come their
way it is right that we put our help
towards the most vulnerable families and
that's by and large what we've been
doing
yeah absolutely the the funding that
we've got um and don't forget we've got
our plan for jobs what we're trying to
do is get more people is it what is that
really true that you're put you're
prioritizing the most vulnerable of
course it is of course it is we're doing
that through our benefit system you do
it through the benefits we're doing it
and also it rises no hang on sorry the
rising universe is about half of what's
so weird
we're doing it through the benefit
system but also we're doing it through
the rise in the national living wage
through the benefit system well we're
doing it through our plan for jobs and
getting more people back into work
that's why we've got more people in work
than ever before certainly since before
the pandemic because the best way to
help people is actually get them out of
the benefits system and into high-paying
jobs so that's what we are doing it
through the benefit system because i i
my understanding is that's not what's
happening well no it is because we've
got a comprehensive benefit system which
has got universal credit and a number of
other elements what's universal credit
going up by so universal credit is
targeted at the most vulnerable people
um and of course also we have rise in
the netherlands by three point is it
three point seven percent i believe and
inflation is set to peak at eight
percent yeah because that's just one
element as i said of the support package
which includes specific helpful council
tax for a whole load of other costs that
people will be incurring so overall
across the piece what we're doing is
helping people with the impacts on their
on their pockets and their household
budgets okay and now the chief whip is
investigating uh a conservative mp
reports that he was watching pornography
on his phone in the house of commons
i mean this is actually quite
unbelievable what's your reaction to
this i mean as yours is it's just
gruesome
none of us could believe our ears when
we we heard of this allegation
um and
we all spoke to the chief whip
immediately and he said he's going to
take action so you spoke to the chief
whip yes i was there at the meeting and
what was sad
uh
we were just all shocked and horrified i
mean how could it get any worse than
that i mean you're in the house of
parliament and you're supposed to be
legislating and i'm the minister that's
responsible for safeguarding women and
for creating laws that protect women
against sexual harassment and violence
against them in a girl so it's deeply
sickening and disgusting to hear that a
male mp is watching porn what should be
done
um
when that person is found or i guess the
name is already known
i don't know the name but the chief whip
of course is going to of course he's
investigating it already he's already
said that he said that as soon as the
allegation was made
action needs to be taken i very much
hope that this person will be we'll see
him out of parliament out of the party
so you think that he'll be out you'd
like to see him out of parliament i i
would hope that's where we get to but i
mean of course we have to hear the full
facts of the case we've only heard one
side of the story but that's already
that's already starting to happen but i
just want to be clear it's completely
and utterly shocking and unacceptable
but you think that he should be out of
parliament and also i guess at the
conservative party as well oh
there's no place for this in our party
um obviously comes after the mail on
sunday uh front page or not front page
that was inside the paper wasn't it and
we should hopefully be able to see it on
the screens just to remind viewers if if
they don't remember it but this is
effectively angerina deputy leader of
the labour party uh the story about her
using a basic basic instinct of
[Music]
tactics to effectively distract boris
johnson at prime minister's questions i
mean it's pretty sexist stuff isn't it
it's deeply sexist it's sexy it's come
from it sounds like the source of the
story were
mps again conception yeah and again you
know i don't know the source of the
story it's been reported in the papers
it's deeply sexist it's unacceptable and
all of us get it all the time we get it
in public life we get it in parliament
it exists on all sides of the house
it's completely wrong and i think
obviously the prime minister's right
when he said it has no place in our
politics and again i understand the
chief whip is taking action we need to
find out who said these things when you
say that we've all had it we've what do
you mean by that what what kind of what
have you all had well we all get we all
get derogatory comments about our
appearance
about the things that we say
any any woman in public life will get it
i'm sure you probably get it as well
it's a common experience that we get
what i would like is to get away from
that and to actually focus on what we're
doing the policies that we're enacting
the really good things that we are doing
for the women in this country that i'm
actually very proud to be doing and i
think it's a shame that i'm having to
come here talking to you and actually
using a valuable time when i could be
talking about the amazing response to
domestic abuse that's what makes me the
most angry actually i can i do sort of
get that and it does feel doesn't it
that
these kind of stories come up every once
in a while we talk about them and then
they kind of fade into the background
yeah
does westminster do you think have a
particular sexism problem
i mean look we're 650 people aren't we
so if you take 650 members of the public
would you find sexist attitudes almost
certainly we're in the spotlight we are
expected to be to be
possibly held to a higher standard i
think rightly so
i find it completely i just find it
disgusting and i just can't see how it
can get any any worse than that and it's
just so frustrating because i came into
politics to do good things i came into
politics to do good things for women
not to have to come onto programs like
this and talk about sexism and misogyny
and all that kind of disgusting stuff
that belongs in the gutter
that makes a lot of sense and thank you
so much for coming on and speaking so
like forcefully about some of these
issues around women in parliament thank
rachel mclean uh there now a bit later
on we're getting later's take on all of
that uh but now we can try and get uh
the take of our deputy political editor
sam coats who joins us now
um sam we're just talking with rachel
mclean about the sort of sexism uh in
parliament and it does feel like this is
all everyone is talking about in
westminster at the minute doesn't it it
does we are a week away from local
elections but this has dominated for the
last few days there are a number of
stories that are having quite a big
impact at the moment you mentioned the
care home uh thing rachel also talked
about that it's interesting just going
through what rachel said rachel told you
that she hadn't had time to read the
judgment that came out today on uh care
homes from the high court it's actually
three pages the summary so uh took me
about three minutes but she doesn't
appear to have had time to do that um
she said uh that she uh that at all
times the government uh were following
the advice of the clinicians of course
the point that the high court were
making was that patrick valance was
saying on the radio so the chief
scientific advisor was saying on the
radio that there might be asymptomatic
transmission at the same time that they
were sending old people back from
older people back from hospitals uh to
care homes so i think these kinds of
judgments by the court
trigger big problems uh for uh
politicians but ultimately political
verdicts uh thank you very much for uh
fact-checking uh some of
uh the interviews good to talk to you
we'll talk to you later on lots to cover
this evening so let's get labour's take
now because we're joined by the parties
shadow chief secretary to the treasury
that is pat mcfadden thank you very much
for being
with us we're just talking there about
uh the care home story uh with uh sam
coats um the government um we heard that
from rachel mclean saying that look it
was a fast-moving situation and they
were following the advice of the
clinicians and actually some of our
viewers seem to have a bit of sympathy
with that argument do you
well the verdict
stands for itself that it was just to be
illegal but from what i've heard of the
reaction to the verdict it seems to be
based on how could we know we didn't
know about asymptomatic
transmission
and
the truth is even
before the
pandemic really took its biggest grip
there was a lot of talk about this there
were articles in the lancet there was
the interview from patrick valance that
we've heard of there was in fact
discussion of asymptomatic transmission
as far back as january two months before
the lockdown we were just learning about
covid
so i think it's part of a broader
problem with what happened in care homes
i mean i remember
writing to the prime minister
at the end of march 2020 after he
promised my colleague peter kyle that
care homes would have all the ppe they
would need by the end of the week
and it was months before they had the
ppe that they needed so it's not just
the release from hospitals it was the
fact that
their care home system was left to fight
this
and it really in many ways was hung out
to dry okay
um i'm keen to talk a bit about the
sexism uh story the storm if you like
that is kind of engulfing at westminster
at the minute and rachel mclean just
said that whoever the mp is they
shouldn't be in parliament anymore uh
the person who is expect allegedly
watching pornography in the chamber do
you agree with that should they be
kicked out of parliament yeah i do i
think um
i think it's a really
depressing story and it also comes after
a number of other stories you've had the
story in the sunday papers that over 50
mps have been referred to
the independent watchdog you've had the
angela raynor story in recent days and
all of this is out of time
and
women in politics today women in
journalism today are not going to put up
with the kind of language and behavior
that might have been common decades ago
times have changed broadly on this front
i think
in society they've changed for the
better but these stories suggest that
there are
parts of politics where that's not
happening have you witnessed anything
i mean i haven't but it's
you know parliament it's a
it's a it's a place that's full of
hierarchy for a start which i think is
unhealthy
where mps are placed on a certain kind
of pedestal and that hierarchy i think
can create unhealthy relationships uh
between
mps and staff particularly if the mp is
the sort of person that might abuse that
so i think that's a problem with it but
there's another part of this i think
uh
is to be considered is when the public
are hearing all of this
the danger is that they conclude that
everybody who's in politics
is a knave a rogue a bully whatever
and actually while everybody should be
held to account for their actions
including this
person that you raised at the beginning
it is important that this is seen as a
public service politics is still the
arena
through which the country resolves its
big questions
and there are some bad people in it but
there are also
some very good public servants in it too
um i just want to talk a little bit
about labour's position we've got those
important local elections uh next week
now if you just look at the political
situation you've got a prime minister
who eight out of ten people think is a
liar over partygate
you've got a conservative mp who is
allegedly watching actual pornography
inside the house of commons chamber
you've got a cost of living crisis
that's expected to
reduce living standards by a faster
amount than any time in history in the
record since we have records began
shouldn't you be absolutely pummeling
the conservatives in the polls why
aren't you cutting three more
well look i think we're making progress
uh you're right about all those things
but the context for the start of this is
the worst
election result that we had for this is
two years ago you can't keep blaming
jeremy corbyn two years ago i know i
know kirsten would love to differentiate
himself against jeremy corbyn but at
some point surely
let me give you another example from
history then i mean
i was involved in the new labour
rebuilding uh in the
1990s uh and
the the work that
new labour did building and the work
that neil kinnick and john smith had
done took a long long time we're trying
to do that task
in a four-year period so in that two
years plus since that worst election
uh results since 1935 we've made great
progress
we've got a new shadow cabinet team in
place we are campaigning hard on the
cost of living we are ahead in the polls
but of course i agree with you after a
result like that after such an emphatic
rejection you have to work very hard to
regain public trust and that's what
we're all focused on no connecting when
did he
no but i don't think that the
achievements of new labour would have
happened without the efforts that he put
in everybody's standing on the shoulders
of who came before them we made progress
underneath so his case diamond no
kinnick you think no but i think he's
got a task of rebuilding
that took longer in the past he's trying
to concertina
that into four years
so i think he's made really good
progress
but he if he was sitting here would
agree with me that of course we've got a
lot more to do okay thank you very much
uh pat mcfadden uh there you are
watching the take we are live in
westminster up next we're going to hear
our question of the week where we give a
backbencher a chance to respond to the
prime minister
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i love my job because
i get to do something that is
contributing to a better future
[Music]
[Music]
hello welcome back live to westminster
you're watching the take
now the political highlights of midweek
at least if you're a bit of a geek like
me prime minister's questions when the
pm faces party leaders and backbenchers
from all sides here's what our political
correspondent joe pike made of it in
pmq's unwrapped
today's prime minister's questions was
not about answers
mr speaker it sounds like the copical
alley of the cost of living crisis
that would not have happened mr speaker
if we listened
to captain hindsight this must be the
oxford union debating skills we've been
hearing so much about everywhere you
look at labour administration it is a
bankrupt shambles
at the final parliamentary fracar before
the local elections party leaders each
made their last ditch pitch with labour
and the snp repeating their core
campaign messages on the cost of living
crisis
a vote for labor next week is a vote for
a very different set of persons
of convening a tory talking shop at
cabinet the prime minister should be
acting to help those children and help
families through the cost of living
emergency
in contrast boris johnson focused on
attacking labour's own record in local
and national government
never forget labour run britain in 2010
bankrupt because of what the labor
government did this guy is doomed to be
a permanent spectator mr speaker because
they have they have no we have a plan to
fix the nhs and fix social care they
have no plan
now if you look at the language
kiyostama used today he was shamelessly
repeating his line that labour is the
party of working people and at the
bottom you can see tax and cost of
living featured a lot too
the words boris johnson used the most
were people
followed by labour a sure sign of his
strategy his approach that he believes
one of the best forms of defense is to
go on the attack as today's session
started news broke that conservative
whips are investigating claims one of
their own mps was spotted watching
pornography in the commons chamber it
feeds into a wider debate about changing
the culture within the walls of
westminster especially after the
controversial angelarena leg crossing
claims in the mail on sunday the source
of which was a tory mp
i know the prime minister will have
whipped his backbenchers to scream and
shout
and that's fine
that's fine
but i hope i hope he's also sent a clear
message that there's no place
for sexism and misogyny i uh exchanged
uh messages with the right honourable
lady over the weekend and i i repeat
what i said to her there could be
absolutely no place uh for such behavior
it was striking that today kierstama was
flanked by women whilst boris johnson
was surrounded by men labor sources
suggest that was by accident rather than
design but allegations of sleaze in
politics seem unlikely to go away 56
members of this house are under
investigation for sexual misconduct
and that includes three of his cabinet
ministers so can he now confirm whether
he considers that sexual harassment
apparently unlike bullying and lying
is grounds for dismissal under the
ministerial code of course it's grounds
for dismissal
that was the final prime minister's
questions for three weeks it'll be back
after the local elections and the
queen's speech and the fortunes of all
the parties and their leaders may well
have changed by then
well pretty lively promises questions as
you would expect this close to a local
election so let's find out what everyone
watching on sky news made of it all uh
our panel is back hello to everyone uh
first can we just get a quick show of
hands if you think boris johnson won
that promises question session put your
hand up now
who thought boris johnson came out best
one two
two hands up i think three hands up
and if you thought kirsten win won that
session put your hand up now
who you thought kissed number one one
two three four oh he's just squeaked it
there four versus three according to our
uh viewers uh panel uh let's talk to uh
belinda uh shall we this is belinda a
campbell you've described yourself as a
swing voter uh belinda uh don't you
first of all i've got to ask about the
burning question of the day the mp
caught watching pawn
allegedly in the chamber
how troubled are you by this story
i think that's taking a real risk
everybody knows in every workplace in
the contracts you read you never do
things like that
you know whether you get dismissed or
get a warning before you get dismissed
everybody knows you don't do that and i
wonder whether he was being insulting to
the person or the people sitting next
door to him or getting some attention in
some way
having a dig it definitely is taking a
risk so it doesn't seem very intelligent
thing to do and obviously it's insulting
yeah not very intelligent it's probably
a bit of an understatement there isn't
it and we can talk now to uh vic daniels
you're a conservative supporter aren't
you
vic although you say that you might not
vote for them next time which i think is
quite interesting but just quickly why
might you not vote for them next time
well the party that i voted for since
1979 didn't exist anymore
um you know we were never a party that
believed in in tax and as kiestama said
you know we've now had 15 tax rights
so um the party that i grew up with and
voted for ever since maggie thatcher was
became prime minister um as i say no
longer exists and what's your take on
the porngate story is it something that
bothers you
well you know i've got here the seven
principles of public life right self
selflessness integrity objectivity
accountability openness honesty and
leadership right i struggle
to work out
uh you know how allegedly watching paul
in the house of commons chamber actually
fits in there yeah that's definitely
fair enough right let's go to pradeep
charlie this is pretty good
uh pretty let's uh ask you about this uh
pornography story
people have been pretty scathing so far
um do you think it's a storm in the tea
cup or do you think it's pretty serious
that someone was doing this
i think it's very serious i think it's
disgusting i do believe the individual
needs some kind of therapy there might
be underlying issues there i do believe
the individual should be kicked out of
parliament and his party and also
identified and if you identify these
individuals it becomes a deterrent i'm
not sure why we should have a deterrent
to do these things but it does become
very deterrent
and we really should have a long hard
look at ourselves because we're setting
example for the next generation and no
wonder the younger generation are
disconnected and disillusioned with
politics nowadays
our guests today have said that whoever
was caught watching it should resign if
you think that they should be kicked out
of parliament for watching porn on their
phone put your hand up now if they
should be kicked out of parliament
that looks like the majority to me
doesn't it a vast majority uh thanks
very much nearly everyone there uh
stella i think you were the only person
there stella finley who didn't put your
hand up
no i didn't put my hand up um
i don't think you should be kicked out
of parliament um
one thing is um we're assuming that it
was a a man who was watching the pawn do
we actually know that
so i think i think we do know that
although you are we i think you are
right people would normally assume it
was a man but my understanding is that
according to the mps it was a man yeah
okay
um i think there should be some
disciplinary measures um and i think the
issue isn't
so much with the watching porn i think
it's using a mechanical device in
parliament
um this is a chamber where people are
supposed to be legislating and leading
the country
and for anyone to be watching anything
on a
a device like that i think is wrong so
it it i don't think for me the big issue
is that he was watching poor he or she
was watching porn i think it's that they
were using
some device and that their mind was
taken away from the issues that were
happening in the chamber it's a good
point isn't it you can't really be
listening very well if you're if you're
looking at watching videos on your
mobile phone uh thank you very much for
a really lively panel this week it's
been fascinating to talk to you this is
one of my favorite bits of the show so
it's always good to get your views
now it's our regular chance to speak to
an mp as we pick our prime minister's
question of the week now that's the one
that really caught our eye during the
session earlier and today
it's this one
today a court has found that the
government acted unlawfully when its
policies led to the discharge of
untested patients from hospitals to care
homes at the start of the pandemic the
court also found no evidence that the
former health secretary addressed the
issue of the aristocare home residents
of such transmission despite the
government insisting at the time that a
protective ring had been thrown around
care homes
the government has once again been found
to have broken the law yep will the
prime minister
apologize to the families of the
thousands and thousands of people who
died in care homes in the first half of
2020 and will he also apologize to care
workers for the shameful comment that he
made in july 2020 when he said that too
many care homes didn't follow procedures
in the way that they could have
daisy cooper there if you just saw me
lunging out of shot it was because i was
just grabbing my
her questions for our next guest of
course the question doesn't usually get
a chance to respond to the prime
minister's answer but this is a part of
the show where we try and put that right
and each week let an mp do just that now
the question we heard was from daisy
cooper the lib dem
asking about the ruling from the high
court today that said the government
acted unlawfully by discharging untested
patients to care homes during the
pandemic
and can speak to daisy now so daisy what
did you make of the
prime minister's response to you well it
was very disappointing because the prime
minister claimed that the government
didn't know enough about asymptomatic um
transmission of covid and that's simply
not correct the whole point of the court
finding today was that it was precisely
because the government did know that
asymptomatic transmission was happening
and didn't do anything about it for
several weeks then that's precisely the
reason why the government was found to
have acted unlawfully
now the prime minister also asked where
your leader ed davey was in the house of
commons today now he actually tweeted uh
to say uh hi boris johnson
i'm out talking with farmers in
winchester today a lot say they'll never
vote conservative again certainly a
better use of my time than listening to
more of your lies so and he's included a
picture of himself there in front of a
very colorful field
the fact that ed davie is out
effectively campaigning for the local
elections is that a sign that you're a
bit worried about how they're going to
go
no quite the opposite um we know that we
are fighting really hard in a number of
places across the country in these local
elections to win seats off the
conservatives uh ed davey was in
winchester uh with a farmer who's one of
the top farmers in the country who has
just decided to join the liberal
democrats but on the basis that we are
now the voice of farmers
in the uk
and so actually we are looking forward
to some good results next week so what
would good results look like because
let's be honest uh you know we've heard
this before you know i remember like you
know talking to people like jose winston
before elections and then being
lib dem has been very disappointed with
the results what would a good night be
for the lib dems
well it's very hard to put a number on
it
and liberal democrats never take any
votes for granted so we will be working
incredibly hard but really what we're
hoping to see are some gains in our blue
wall areas so in my seat officer albums
which also includes harpenden
is in south cambridgeshire in wimbledon
in south london there's a number of
places where the liberal democrats are
the key challenges to the conservatives
and we're hoping to make gains
now this question might sound a bit
flippant but i actually don't mean it to
be because i think it is a question that
voters will be asking ahead of the local
elections you know what is the point of
the lib dams
well the fact is liberal democrats are
internationalists we're
environmentalists we are pro-business
we're pro-public service and i think
what we've seen over the years is that
there are many people who share our
values and they feel that we share their
values and they share ours and we saw in
both cheshire and amisham
and in north shropshire in those two
areas that have been traditionally true
blue areas for hundreds of years several
people realize that they shared our
values and recognized that we work
incredibly hard to win their support
their trust and their votes and they
decided that we were better
representatives of them and their
communities
and now i just want to talk to you about
a story that we've been discussing a lot
on the programme today and that is
sexism you know in westminster you know
we saw the mail on sunday a story about
angela rainer crossing and crossing her
legs
while sitting down shockingly
the number of complaints there had been
about
allegations of sexual harassment
in westminster and now of course this
story about a male mp watching
pornography in the chamber
what's your you're relatively new to
westminster what's your experience of
being a woman in westminster is that a
sexist place
well i think almost every single woman
in westminster whether they're an mp or
whether they're a member of staff
working for an mp or on the
parliamentary estates will have either
experienced or seen some form of sexism
or misogyny obviously for me personally
for a lot of a lot of the time i've been
an mp we've been working through a
virtual parliament because of the
pandemic um but certainly it's obvious
that there is a real culture of sexism
and misogyny here that we really have to
tackle i think today's news especially
about an mp reportedly watching porn in
the chamber is just really disgusting
quite frankly you know there are good
reasons why mps might need to check
their phones occasionally whilst they're
in the chamber often to check the claims
that are being made at the dispatch box
or to respond to urban urgent
constituency cases that they know are
coming in that day but sitting and
watching a porn site whilst you should
be listening to a parliamentary debate
it's just almost incomprehensible
okay daisy cooper thank you very much
for being on the program uh today mp
therefore senate albums
you're watching the take live in
westminster up next we're going to be
rounding up everything we've heard and
doing a bit of post-match analysis
[Music]
look at that sheet of flavor and it's
moving this way
and over there is dover we track the
changes happening to our world right now
i think it's a procession of the taliban
there they are right here would you as
prime minister be able to look them in
the face let's have a look at both of
those two things i just want to say
thank you for having the courage to
speak to us we do genuinely believe in
what we do to show the truth
i thought there was an astonishing story
there
independent united kingdom
[Applause]
these last few years have seen some huge
stories
and these stories have been driven by
politics by politicians the people in
power
you must stay at home and it's my job to
figure out how these decisions made by
politicians impact all of us in our
everyday lives this is the worst thing
i've ever been through in my life people
turn up here with their child stuff in a
black sack and just say i don't want to
and that is what it is it's first class
poverty
is this an example of the welfare state
failing
we take you to the heart of the stories
that shape our world
these are stories that affect us all
millions of children are now having to
catch up
some stories have changed all of our
lives because like the residents the
staff are being infected
politicians they make decisions all of
the time and it's our job to hold them
to account i wonder if you will take
this opportunity to apologize to those
families but in the end
the real power doesn't actually lie with
the politicians
the real power
lies with the people
i'm nick martin i'm the people and
politics correspondent at sky news
[Music]
we support communities to grow food in
lost and unloved spaces across the city
so our main kind of driving force is to
get people growing
[Music]
[Music]
i love my job because
i get to do something that is
contributing to a better future
[Music]
[Music]
hello welcome back live to westminster
this is the take
well we've had plenty of takes this
evening so time now for a bit of
post-match analysis with our deputy
political editor sam coats who is here
again
sam we've just heard from daisy cooper
from the lib dems uh who wouldn't say
what a good night was but she was
confident of taking lots of seats off
boris johnson what would a good like
night be well we can answer that
question pretty directly courtesy of
michael thrasher's guys election analyst
and if the liberal democrats add about
50 to 100 councillors uh next thursday
that will be deemed to be a good night
um now the number that we're really
looking at will be the tory number if
the tories now the tweet is probably
going to lose and that's going to put
pressure on boris johnson if they lose
as many as 350
councillors and that really is going to
be a bad night 100 150 they might be
able to put that to um towards midterm
blues but really i think people in
westminster are going to be looking at
whether or not there is a read across
from what happens in the country next
thursday to what might happen in the
future future general election and of
course pressure on boris johnson as well
how it boris johnson's whole numbers
looking well it's absolutely fascinating
let's uh let's look at his paul ratings
at the moment what people think of him
personally how is boris johnson doing
now if you look at the blue line that
people who think he's doing well the red
line that's people who think he's doing
badly and you can see
really since
pretty much this time last year since
the local elections he's a majority of
people think that he is doing uh badly
more people think that he is doing badly
by quite a big margin i think he's doing
well this is the thing that's animating
conservative mps that's suggesting uh to
them that he might not be the winner uh
that he perhaps once was even uh as
recently as a year ago pretty bad trends
for him the question is can he recover
uh his halo given just how many don't
people don't think he uh is doing well
but it's quite clear these are bad
numbers for boris johnson but look at
this it's kirsten's numbers remember
that pattern that we've just seen
and it's actually quite similar when you
get to kierstama so here we have the
number of people that think he's doing
badly and again more people think that
kierstama is doing badly than he's doing
well and trending the wrong way as well
for kirstalma absolutely you've got uh
perhaps around the turn of the year some
people thinking uh kirsten was doing a
bit better but then you've seen his
numbers uh according to yougov tail off
once again
and i think that this is one of the
things that's uh
causing pause for thought amongst
particularly tory mps who after the
local election are going to start
thinking about whether or not they want
to keep boris johnson the lighter party
gate and like what seems i think to them
like endless troubles perhaps boris
johnson is less popular than he once was
but who can beat kierstarma and is he
actually beatable given his personal
ratings aren't so good as perhaps uh
some of the polls suggest people do
think that kiersten was marginally more
competent that's the red line
here than
boris johnson but actually when you look
at key metrics like competence what
strikes me is just how similar people
think they are so perhaps kiss might
just be seen as beatable still by tory
mps uh fascinating uh stuff as always uh
always enjoy the analysis thank you very
much sam
coates now we do have a bit of breaking
news in the last few minutes before we
go because we've just had this from the
conservative chief whip looking of
course into
those pornography allegations following
allegations of inappropriate behaviour
in the house of commons the chief whip
has asked that this matter be referred
to the icgs that's parliament's watchdog
upon the conclusion of any icgs
investigation the chief whip will take
appropriate action appropriate action
what is that going to be certainly uh
the mps on the take tonight thought that
it was something that the person should
be kicked out of parliament for
well uh busy show today our sunday show
is a bit of an election special this
week as well that safety ridge on sunday
we'll be hearing from the labour leaders
okay stammer the snp leader and scottish
first minister nicola sturgeon plus the
leaders of the lib dems greeds and blood
comray plus the conservatives of course
it's a busy one see you then
[Music]
b
[Music]
the
[Music]
[Music]
you